النار وصلت الى قبه الكرملين لكنها لم
تخترقها طائرتان مسيرتان تخططا جميع انظمه
الدفاع الروسيه وتمكنت من الوصول الى مقر
راس السلطه في موسكو والهدف اغتيال الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين لكن هل من السهل
استهداف قيصر روسيا
يضم جهاز الامن التابع للرئيس الروسي 9000
شخص بوظائف مختلفه بينها 850 حارسا شخصيا
وحده حراسه بوت تسمى الفرسان وهي وحده
خاصه تابعه لجهاز خدمه الحمايه الفيدراليه
الروسيه وبحسب موقع رشا بيوند فان عناصر
تلك الوحده هم الافضل والاكثر تميزا بين
عناصر الجهاز كاملا اختيار افراد وحده
الفرسان يكون بناء على صفات محدده تشمل
علم النفس والقدره على التحمل البدني
وتحمل البرد وعدم التعرق في الحراره
ويتعين ان يكون الحارس قادرا على التكهن
بالتهديدات ومنعها والقيام بذلك دون ان
يلاحظه الاخرون ويجب ان يكون عمره دون
الخامسه والثلاثين وطوله بين 175
و190 سنتيمترا ووزنه ما بين 75
وتسعين كيلو جراما
الرئيس الروسي يحيط نفسه بنخبه من الحراس
الشخصيين ذوي الكفاءه العاليه وحراسه
يشكرون درعا يقيه من التهديدات بجميع
اشكالها
افراد حمايه الرئيس الروسي مزودون بدروع
خاصه تستخدم كدرع لحمايه بوتين ويحملون
موسى من طراز فيكتور عيار 9 مليمترات
تحتوي على رصاص خارق للدروع كما ان بوتين
نفسه يرتدي دائما بدله واقيه كامله بحسب
نيويورك بوستا قبل شهور من ظهور بوتين باي
مكان عام يستعد فريقه الامني بطاقته
الكامله يبدا عمله بتحليل جميع التهديدات
الممكنه كاي نشاط اجرامي او اضطرابات وحتى
امكانيه حدوث كوارث طبيعيه وقبل السفر
للخارج يستكشف الفريق وجهه سفر الرئيس
ويقوم بفحص المكان الذي سيقيم فيه مع
تثبيت اجهزه تشويش لمنع تفجير القنابل عن
بعد كما يجري الفنيون مراقبه الكترونيه
للهواتف المحموله والاجهزه الاخرى في
المنطقه وفي الجو ترافق الطائره الرئاس
المقاتلات اليوشن اي ال 76 يهتم فريق
حراسه بوتين بكل شيء حتى اصلاح مقابض
الابواب بحيث لا تكون هناك حاجه لدخول اي
فنيين او غيرهم الى المكان اثناء اقامته
اما التنقلات بوتين فتتم بسياره رئاسيه
مصفحه ترافقها قافله من عربات مدرعه ثقيله
تحمل جنودا من القوات الخاصه مسلحين
ببنادق كلاشنكوف وقاذفات قنابل يدويه
مضاده للدبابات وصواريخ محموله مضاده
للطائرات وحين يخرج من السياره تحيط به
اربع حلقات امنيه وحراس متخفون وسط الحشود
وقناصه على اسطح المباني المحيطه اضافه
الى فريق طبي وشخص مخصص لتذوق كل وجبه
تقدم له لضمان عدم تعرضه للتسمم تامين
مبنى الكرملين وحمايته ليس اق اهميه من
تامين بوتين فاصلحه محصنه بانظمه صواريخ
مصممه لاعتراض الطائرات والصواريخ وكذلك
الامر مع العديد من المباني الحكوميه
والاداريه في موسكو واهم تلك الانظمه
الدفاعيه نظامه صواريخ
المتواجد على اسطح مباني قريبه من
الكرملين
تستخدم موسكو انظمه دفاعيه قصيره الى
متوسطه ضد الطائرات والمروحيات وصواريخ
كروز التي تطير على ارتفاع منخفض كما يمكن
استخدامها ايضا ضد اهداف اصغر مثل
الطائرات المسيره
نخبه النخبه هذا اقل ما يقال عن دوائر
الحمايه المحيطه ببوتان الامر الذي يجعل
من فرضيه اغتياله امرا صعب المنهل فكيف
لطائرتين مسيرتين صغيرتين ان تصله الى
قيصر روسيا